this is a European warship conducting
security operations in this area if you
observe any suspicious or illegal
activity require assistance pull entire
one six out
it's the early 2000s and Somali pirates
operating in the Gulf of Aden are
terrorizing international shipping and
jeopardizing the supply of vital food a
to Somalia the increasing threat at sea
combined with a humanitarian disaster on
land places the EU in a tough position
to act or not to act
intensive consultation at national and
European level results in a uniform alia
operation Atalanta the first naval
mission ever undertaken by the EU the
main challenges were of course embracing
a European Union the first maritime
mission against a very difficult
adversary and how to bring that together
a very long way from Europe and sustain
that operation through a considerable
period of time one aspect of EU nerve
force mandate is to protect vulnerable
ships and vessels carrying humanitarian
aid from pirate attacks but with up to
5,000 ships a month transiting the Gulf
of Aden and an area of operations one
and a half times the size of Europe this
is no easy task the key to success is
the teamwork we work very closely in
partnership with NATO who have a force
out there and the combined maritime
force based in Bahrain it's been the one
of the most interesting operations in
that it has brought exceptional
cooperation the sort of cooperation I
just don't think it happened on land
that has been available to us at sea
with several warships operating together
under the EU now for flag' the number of
attacks is reduced dramatically the
Atalanta is probably the most
outstanding success story of CSDP but
fighting pirates at sea is not enough
you have to do something about the root
causes people are becoming pirates not
because it's romantic but it's a good
business so we need to open new
perspectives for the country
with tactical success at sea the next
challenge together with the African
Union's mission to Somalia is to
strengthen Somalis embryonic army to
counter the threat of al-shabaab a huge
task the EU military training mission
for Somalia can't and Amir said in
African are concealed the concept
dilemma zone and are commissioned a pair
of la Somali triple it is a key for a
teleport in equal in European KT accrue
sa investi a traveler program de
formación
ATM canoes affordability one mil
Khambatta Somalia this is a country that
has been without a function state for 22
years so we should not expect that
things will be easy but we have a new
momentum and energy to be forward the EU
training mission was outside Somalia
before now they are relocated into
Somalia and they are going to train the
Somalis inside Somalia in a region
devastated by two decades of civil war
security needs are as pressing as social
and economic ones
so the only effective response is a
comprehensive approach it was very
obvious we needed a cohesive coherent
approach if we were going to help the
Somali people realize their ambitions
since then we've brought the full
support of the European Union to Somalia
and to the wider region and I want to
assure the Somalian people that we will
stand with them for the future
what's important to understand is that
the Europeans unions ability to begin to
amalgamate the various strengths it has
these are humanitarian it is
developmental it is now security this is
the union beginning to give clouds to
what it claims to be
building on the successes of EU nav for
and the training mission to Somalia in
2012 the EU launches you captain esto
the first capacity-building mission with
a truly regional approach a simple knock
on door a freak the control Illawarra
space my team the fashion ivt not a mall
apparatus so to further the legislation
if you see demand teams at idea or the
rapidity of the call to the Mahina this
one confirm with you to control is at
this pass animate reason is it Federica
ski is an experienced French gendarme
embedded in the Djiboutian Coast Guard
his task is to help train this incipient
force boudoir deformation the chemo
don't Kenmore me okay [ __ ] deserve a
fair to token Okun's law provision I
love pork oil facility like the Coast
Guard the Navy is also in strong need of
support today the arrival of the Spanish
warship
meteora provides the best platform for a
joint Navy Coast Guard diving exercise
they gon star alecky for the most armies
every time when a ship goes to Lu to a
jetty or to appear we inspect the jetty
itself is there is any suspicious object
and then if the ship is in harbour we
inspect also the hull in order to see if
there is any threat to the hull or any
damage
another important task of you captain s
tour is to help the countries in the
Horn of Africa strengthen their laws to
be able to fight piracy and other crimes
on the high seas such as illegal
fisheries and trafficking we are working
in post-conflict societies and they're
one of the first priorities is to make
police and justice work again
in the aftermath of the Balkan wars
member states realized the need for the
EU to act as a security provider laying
the foundations for Europe's common
security and defence policy
csdp was born out of frustration we we
so that we were not effective enough at
the same time it's our backyard so that
was the realization of the mid 90s and
then it gave a very important impulse to
the development of a new policy that
puts them written down in the treaties
and implemented as of 2003 in the field
a decade later the II use common
security and defence policy as a proven
track record of success in both military
operations and civilian crisis
management the challenge now is to
sustain this position in the light of
changing threats and shrinking budgets
to this occasion the pin G's and Ernie
of organically zahavy are the Foxes on a
DP European so explain mantras on port
on the situational concern that no news
of leaves the lipid if Europe is to reap
the full benefits of its common defense
and security policy it's also necessary
that Europeans invest sufficiently in
robust military capabilities we have our
limits in terms of sustainability in
terms of complexity of military
operations that's why we try to improve
our capabilities particularly in the
area of air-to-air refueling of the
strategic airlift Astrid our Lincoln
unbundle and dealer and also in material
Edmonds and Eva he and his a specific
initiative are a frugal to cut combing
have a good infinite
Dawn's anyway and he'll go to stop for
that
we spent 200 billion euros a year on
defense and European Union so if I turn
that into a challenge and an opportunity
I think we really do have to do more now
to try and work collectively
strengthening Europe's military muscle
by pooling and sharing key resources may
also boost its economy the deficit and
any employment of the quasars a crayon
president watt more callously
I don't see traceable sector due
deference key television Doh Novation
technology issue GN to them to the
sector economy in maximizing synergies
between civilian and military operations
in the Horn of Africa the EU has
contributed positively to the stability
of a region ravaged by war and poverty
but in the face of increasing security
challenges in the world
how will the EU role as a provider of
security evolve in the future we will be
wherever will be needed csdp is demand
driven we engage in countries and
regions where we can make a difference
but of course we have to be well
prepared to react the potential is there
we just need to make sure that we can
use it
you